bienvenidos de nuevo ahora los voy a
introducir a los conceptos de trabajo y
energía y estas son dos palabras que
estoy seguro que ya ocupas en tu vida y
tienes cierta noción de lo que
significan pero quizás no en el contexto
de física aunque no están del todo
separados así que el primero de ellos es
trabajo ok la definición de trabajo y
esta definición la obtuve de de
wikipedia y de hecho se van a ver y se
van a dar cuenta de lo chistoso que son
estas definiciones porque resultan un
tanto digamos circulares entonces el
trabajo está definido como la energía la
energía transferida por una fuerza
ok vamos a definirlo como la energía
transferida por
una fuerza muy bien y entonces tú a lo
mejor bueno o sea tú no entiende muy
bien que es el trabajo cuando que es
como cuando haces algo digamos no pero
en física esta definición como te
comentaba es un poco circular ya que
veamos las matemáticas o las ecuaciones
detrás del trabajo y la energía vas a
tener más noción de qué es esto pero
aquí nos dice es la energía transferida
por una fuerza entonces tú me puedes
decir ok si entiendo que es una fuerza
ya hemos visto varios videos y muchos
ejercicios sobre fuerza pero entonces
qué es la energía verdad y aquí más o
menos nos está dando una idea de que se
está realizando algo verdad hay una
transferencia de energía entonces la
definición de energía energía que
también encontré en wikipedia y por eso
me parece bastante chistoso es
justamente la habilidad la habilidad
para realizar un trabajo
para realizar
trabajo entonces como podrás darte
cuenta estas dos cosas están definidas
digamos mutuamente verdad el trabajo se
define a partir de la energía y la
energía a partir del trabajo entonces
estas son las mejores definiciones que
pude hallar digamos las más digamos
intuitivas quizá sí y no realmente no da
mucha explicación de lo que es así que
vamos a movernos a las ecuaciones para
entenderlo entonces el trabajo
matemáticamente el trabajo vamos a
definirlo como la fuerza aplicada a un
objeto por el desplazamiento el
desplazamiento que digamos que ocurre
sobre ese objeto es decir por ejemplo
supongan si ustedes que tienen un bloque
citó aunque digamos tenemos aquí un
bloque y tiene un peso de 10 newtons ok
perdón más bien vamos a aplicar una
fuerza de 10 newton sobre sobre este
objeto ok
tiene este objeto lo que tendrá cierta
masa ok y digamos que al aplicarle esta
fuerza ocurre un desplazamiento de 7
metros ok entonces ocurrieron ocurrió un
desplazamiento desplazamiento de 7
metros
esta fórmula del trabajo nos dice que el
trabajo realizado digamos el trabajo
realizado sería la fuerza que en nuestro
caso son 10 newtons y multiplicamos por
el desplazamiento que son 7 metros muy
bien entonces si nosotros realizamos las
operaciones simplemente nos queda 10 por
7 son 70 y nos queda newtons por metro y
entonces esta es la unidad con la que
vamos a medir el trabajo y la energía y
que a estos los conocemos como jules
y esto un newton por metro es un joule y
quizás en otros vídeos vean algún otro
tutorial hablemos un poquito de todo lo
que trabajo yul y sobre un poco más
sobre estas unidades pero hasta este
momento vamos a quedarnos con este esta
idea al menos intuitiva de lo que es un
trabajo entonces realmente es una medida
de energía y que la podemos medir como
la fuerza por el desplazamiento muy bien
entonces me voy a quedar con esta
definición de que el trabajo es la
fuerza por el desplazamiento y vamos a
tratar de entender el tipo de trabajo y
la energía de que en realidad es la
energía que se está transfiriendo ok
entonces vamos a tener otro ejemplo
digamos
digamos que tengo un bloque otro bloque
también con una masa m ahora vamos a
fijarnos en su masa y supongamos que
aplicamos una fuerza efe muy bien
tenemos una fuerza de f de hecho vamos a
quitarle la flechita ok ahora tenemos un
desplazamiento de este objeto digamos de
una distancia de ok d es el
desplazamiento de este objeto muy bien
entonces si tenemos este desplazamiento
lo que sabemos es que el trabajo el
trabajo es igual a la fuerza a la fuerza
por distancia verdad
a distancia y entonces uno lo que
tendría que recordar y es todas estas
propiedades de la cinemática y por
ejemplo cuando vimos el tutorial de
movimiento de proyectiles que de hecho
ya ya hemos visto algunas fórmulas de
este tutorial o de esos vídeos vimos que
la velocidad final al cuadrado era igual
a la velocidad inicial al cuadrado más
dos veces la aceleración por esta
distancia verdad entonces ya no vamos a
demostrar esta fórmula ya lo hicimos en
aquel entonces solo vamos a utilizar
esta para deducir otras propiedades del
trabajo ok entonces si nos fijamos en
este tenemos un objeto que estaba en
reposo y que le aplicamos una fuerza
para que se desplace de unidades verdad
una distancia de ahora si estaba en
reposo quiere decir que la velocidad
inicial era cero entonces lo que tenemos
es ya nada más voy a poner ver porque ya
no hay velocidad inicial la velocidad va
a ser igual a dos veces la aceleración
por nuestro desplazamiento muy bien y
ahora bien uno tiene también que
recordar la segunda ley de newton y la
segunda ley de newton nos dice que la
fuerza es igual a la masa por la
aceleración así que la aceleración es
igual a la fuerza entre la masa muy bien
entonces en vez de poner aquí la vamos a
poner que la velocidad al cuadrado es
dos veces la aceleración pero la
aceleración es f
/ m por la distancia
por la distancia muy bien entonces por
ejemplo uno puede sacar raíz cuadrada y
concluir que la velocidad es la raíz
cuadrada de dos veces la fuerza por la
distancia dividido entre la masa muy
bien ahora bien vamos esto de aquí es
muy interesante porque aparece
justamente el trabajo verdad la fuerza
por la distancia que es el trabajo ahora
bien si por ejemplo partimos de aquí
nada más digamos que conocemos nosotros
cuál es la velocidad que lleva nuestro
objeto queremos preguntarnos cuál es el
trabajo que tuvimos que aplicarle para
llegar a esa velocidad entonces tenemos
que la velocidad al cuadrado que la
velocidad al cuadrado es igual a 2 veces
la fuerza por la distancia vamos a
multiplicar estos primero
es igual a 2 veces la fuerza por la
distancia que en nuestro caso es el
trabajo el trabajo y dividido entre m
que es la masa verdad / / m entonces
nosotros podemos despejar quién es el
trabajo porque simplemente pasamos
multiplicando la masa por la velocidad
al cuadrado es 2 veces el trabajo y
ahora dividimos entre 2 y concluimos que
el trabajo es igual a la masa por la
velocidad al cuadrado dividido entre 2 y
esta formulita de aquí es muy
interesante porque si sabemos la
velocidad de un objeto con una masa m
entonces podemos deducir fácilmente cuál
es el trabajo que se aplicó en este
objeto para llegar a esa velocidad muy
bien y de hecho esta formulita es
justamente lo que ahora conocemos como
la energía cinética de esto es por
definición y esencialmente es la energía
debida al movimiento y esta es una
definición de wikipedia es la energía de
vida al movimiento o el trabajo
necesario para acelerar un objeto desde
el reposo a su velocidad actual ok
entonces te dejo con esta fórmula es una
forma de energía es una de las distintas
formas de la energía y en el siguiente
vídeo vamos a platicar de otra forma de
energía y vamos a introducir lo que es
la ley de la conservación de la energía
y que va a ser muy útil para ver cómo se
convierte la energía en un objeto más
bien para ver cómo se convierte la
energía y ver qué pasa con ese objeto al
cual estamos aplicando una fuerza